[موسيقى]
في هذه الليله الليله الماضيه كان هناك
غاره اسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا لعائله نصر
في منطقه حي المناره الى الجنوب من شرق
محافظه خان يونس ادى ذلك الارتقاء اكثر من
18 شهيدا بينهم اربعه الى خمسه اطفال وهذا
المشهد كما تشاهدون في الصوره اعداد
الشهداء وكذلك جثامين الشهداء الان في
ثلاجه الموتى في مستشفى غزه الاوروبي في
محافظه خان يونس يتم الان الاستعدادات من
قبل اهالي الشهداء لتشييع جثامين هؤلاء
الشهداء في مقابر قريبه من مستشفى غزه
الاوروبي برغم ضراوه القصف الاسرائيلي
وكذلك المدفعيه الاسرائيليه اللي تطلق
قذائفها في هذه اللحظات في اكثر من منطقه
من المناطق الشرقيه لمحافظه خانيونس لما
بتطلع من الشباك لم بقولوا ضربوا موسى نصر
صار كل يج وظلنا احنا نايمين يعني ما
بنعلم في شيء يعني قلنا خلص يمكن برا هنا
هنا ل مقطعين يعني م الناس استشهدوا مطلوب
من العالم والشعوب العربيه انهم يقفوا
وقفه واحده ويوقفوا العدوان الاسرائيلي
على غزه باقرب سرعه والا هؤلاء الصهاينه
اليهود ناويين يقتلونا كلنا ما بدهم شعب
ولا مواطن ولا مدني ولا دكتور ولا حدا
بدهم كل الشعب يقتلوه ولازم يقفوا وقفه
واحده والان بسرعه هذا هو دائما مطلب
الشعب الفلسطيني في ظل هذه المحرقه
الاسرائيليه تنفذ بحق ابناء شعبنا
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه دائما هي اوقف
الحرب والجم هذا الاحتلال عن ابناء شعب
قطاع
زه قناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر خان يونس
جنوب قطاع غزه